I've been trapped in a cave in rural
Virginia our safe this morning after an
hours-long rescue emergency crews
scrambled yesterday to bring the group a
back above ground the men had been
exploring the cave when they got
stranded hundreds of feet below the
surface
heavy rain made it difficult to climb
out the rescue took place southwest of
Roanoke in Cleveland Virginia Errol
Barnett is near the scene Errol
good morning a good morning look around
dozens of rescue teams had to hike
through rocky conditions like this with
their heavy equipment to access the so
called Cyclops cave which is located in
a Ridge just to my right once there
these technical teams had to get
underground in very muddy and dark
conditions they also had to widen some
of the passageways they say because they
were so narrow five men emerged alive
Sunday afternoon after being trapped for
hours in a cave in Southwest Virginia
more than three dozen emergency workers
from four states helped bring the men to
safety rescue took more than 14 hours
after first responders arrived early
Sunday morning the search and rescue
coordinator Michael maggot says the type
of cave the men were trapped inside is
defined as wild a one that only
experienced divers should explore they
both got in got fatigued and cold it's
really wet muddy and slippery and they
couldn't get back out emergency workers
say six men ended the cave around 7:00
p.m. Friday evening with the intent of
camping inside overnight at about 2:00
a.m. on Sunday they say one of the men
emerged and called 911 trouble climbing
out Billy crimes is with the Virginia
Department of Emergency Management he
was able to give us a lot of really
valuable information about you know the
the specifics of each individual and how
they were doing crime says rescuers
located the men about a football fields
length from the caves entrance even
though he says that's just a fraction of
the caves more than seven miles of
passages the rescue was tedious the
passageways are not much wider than I am
chesta back deep very physically tight
very small spaces and a very very muddy
cave Eric Stanley was one of the first
rescuers to reach the men once we
realized that everyone was in relatively
good health no one was dangerously
hypothermic then you can kind of relax
take your time make sure everything is
rigged properly and we knew that
ultimately we would be successful with
the resources that we had now all five
men were hospitalized as a result of
this and in addition to not being
prepared for the very wet conditions
which is a result from the heavy rains
here recently rescuers say the men did
not bring enough food or water either
and the cave by the way is on private
property
Nora Wow Errol thank you